ABOUT HIM.
FIRST, THE BIG NEWS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN PLEADED
GUILTY TO LYING TO CONGRESS.
HE CONCEDED THAT HE WAS
INTENTIONALLY WRONG.
HE LIED ABOUT THE DATE OF AN
ABORTED MOSCOW REAL ESTATE DEAL
WHEN HE TESTIFIED FOR THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR.
HIS PLEA WAS OF COURSE BIG NEWS
ON CABLE TELEVISION.
HE RESPONDED TO IT AS WELL, HE
CALLED HIM WEEK AND NOT A VERY
SMART PERSON.
THAT IS OBJECTIVELY TRUE OF
COURSE, IT IS ALSO WORTH ASKING
WHY ANYONE WOULD HIRE A WEAK,
DUMB LAWYER.
FOR NOW, LET'S CONSIDER WHAT WE
HAVE JUST LEARNED ABOUT HOW
WASHINGTON WORKS.
APPARENTLY IT IS NOW AN
ENFORCEABLE FELLA NEED TO LIE TO
THE U.S. CONGRESS.
ON ONE LEVEL THAT IS GOOD NEWS,
WE SHOULD TAKE OUR OWN LAW
SERIOUSLY.
FUNCTIONAL COUNTRIES DO THAT.
PATIENCE AND DECLINE SET UP
SANCTUARY CITIES AND IGNORE
THEIR OWN BORDERS.
MICHAEL COHEN MIGHT HAVE BROKEN
THIS LAW OR REALLY ANY OTHER
LAW.
NOBODY WHO KNOWS HIM A SHOCKED
BY THE ALLEGATION.
IF HE WAS ACCUSED OF RUNNING A
CANNIBALISM BRAIN, YOU'D HAVE TO
AT LEAST TAKE THE CHARGE
SERIOUSLY.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE WITH THAT
GUY.
THREE CHEERS FOR LAWN ORDER, THE
PROBLEM IS IF YOU ARE GOING TO
ENFORCE STATUES, YOU HAVE TO
ENFORCE THEM FAIRLY AND EVENLY.
THE LAST TO APPLY TO EVERYONE.
OTHERWISE IT DOES NOT RELIEVE
THE LAW.
IT IS A POLITICAL WEAPON.
MICHAEL COHEN IS FACING FIVE
YEARS IN PRISON FOR TELLING
CONGRESS SOMETHING THAT HE KNEW
WAS FALSE.
HOW OFTEN DOES THAT HAPPEN IN
WASHINGTON?
IF YOU WATCH C-SPAN YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER, CONSTANTLY.
ACCORDING TO ONE STUDY BETWEEN
THE SECOND WORLD WAR AND 2007, A
TOTAL OF ONLY SIX PEOPLE WERE
CONVICTED OF LYING TO CONGRESS.
SIX PEOPLE AND SIX YEARS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE LAW IS NOT
ENFORCED.
THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE THINK IT SO
OFTEN.
WATCH THIS SWORN TESTIMONY FROM
2013.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING YOU HAVE
NOT HEARD OF, THIS IS THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
HE ASSURES THE CONGRESS UNDER
OATH THAT THE NSA ABSOLUTELY
DOES NOT SPY ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
>> DOES THE NSA COLLECT ANY TYPE
OF DATA AT ALL ON BILLIONS OR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS?
>> NO, SIR.
IT DOES NOT.
>> Tucker: A CLEVER LIVE.
HE IS A LIAR.
THERE IS NO DEBATE ABOUT THAT
AND YET HE WASN'T CHARGED FOR
LIED UNDER OATH.
IN FACT, HE GOT RICHER AFTER HE
RETIRED.
SEED AND HIRED HIM AS AN
ANALYST.
THE SAME THING HAPPENS WITH JIM
COMEY.
IN 2017 HE CLAIMED UNDER
THAT HE HAD NEVER BEEN AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE FOR NEW STORIES
WHILE HE WORKED AT THE FBI.
WATCH HIM TELL THAT LIE TO THE
CONGRESS.
>> DIRECTOR COMEY, HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE AND
NEWS REPORTS ABOUT MATTERS
RELATING TO THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION OR THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION?
>> NEVER APPEARED >> HAVE YOU
EVER AUTHORIZE SOMEONE ELSE AT
THE FBI TO BE AN ANONYMOUS
SOURCE AND NEWS
REPORTS ABOUT THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION FOR THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: ACCORDING TO HIS
LONGTIME DEPUTY WHO WOULD KNOW,
THAT IS ANDREW McCABE, WHAT HE
SET ON THE TAPE YOU JUST SAW IS
TOTALLY UNTRUE.
SO HE LIED TO CONGRESS.
NOBODY CARES.
JIM COMEY WENT ON TO GET RICH AS
A PUNTED SELLING HIS BOOK, THE
SAME PEOPLE ROOTING FOR MICHAEL
COHEN'S DESTRUCTION FOR LYING
CONSIDER JIM COMEY A HERO.
AND THEN THERE IS FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN.
HE LIES CONSTANTLY, THAT IS WELL
DOCUMENTED.
AND 2011 HE CLAIMED THAT DRONES
STRIKES OVERSEAS HAD NEVER TO
HIS KNOWLEDGE KILLED A SINGLE
NONCOMBATANT.
THAT WAS A TOTAL CROCK.
IN 2014 HE LIED AND SAID THE CIA
HAD NOT BROKEN INTO THE
COMPUTERS OF SENATE STAFFERS.
LAST YEAR UNDER OATH BEFORE
CONGRESS HE SAID THIS.
>> TO KNOW IF THE BUREAU EVER
RELIED ON THE DOSSIER AS PART OF
ANY COAT FILINGS?
APPLICATIONS, PETITIONS?
>> I HAVE NO AWARENESS.
SPIRIT OF THE CIA RELY ON IT
>> NO
IT
WAS AT THE BASIS FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE UNITY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A TOTAL
LIE.
A FRAGRANT LIE, A SIGNIFICANT
ONE.
THAT AFFECTS THE LIFE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
AND YET, YOU KNOW HOW THE STORY
ENDS?
HE WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH A
FELONY FOR LYING TO THE
CONGRESS.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
WASHINGTON REWARDED HIM.
HE IS NOW AN ANALYST FOR
NBC NEWS.
HE COULD BE ON THE AIR TONIGHT
TELLING YOU WHY IT IS SO VITALLY
IMPORTANT THAT MICHAEL COHEN WAS
CHARGED WITH LYING TO CONGRESS.
WE CAN'T HAVE THAT.
RULE OF LAW!
LOBLAW.
DO NOTICE A THEME HERE THAT
CONNECTS ALL OF THESE STORIES?
THE WELL-CONNECTED CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THEY CAN LIE TO THE CONGRESS
WITH IMPUNITY AND THEY DO.
THEY CAN LOBBY FOR FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT BOTHERING TO
REGISTER AND THEY DO.
IF THEY ARE RICH ENOUGH THEY CAN
EVEN MOLEST CHILDREN WITHOUT
BEING SERIOUSLY PUNISHED.
HE DID THAT.
NONE OF THIS BY THE WAY IS A
DEFENSE OF MICHAEL COHEN, THAT
GUY IS A GREAT.
HE MAY VERY WELL WIND UP IN
JAIL.
IF HE DOES WIND UP IN JAIL,
LET'S HOPE HE IS THE FIRST IN A